SIMU LIU
I never thought in my wildest dreams
that I would be here.
When they announced this movie
I was like really, really excited.
Kind of tongue-in-cheek
I ended up tweeting Marvel,
"Hey, we gonna talk or what?"
So, I'm very glad I did that.
KEVIN FEIGE
Shang-Chi and the Legend of The Ten Rings!
SIMU LIU
We shot this film in Sydney
over the course
of like, 13 months.
Some days I work out
harder than others.
This is every kid's dream.
A couple of people to say hi to.
It totally was a whirlwind
experience going from city to city...
Seeing the way
that the fans responded.
It was such an incredible
moment for all of us.
This is only the beginning.
SHANG-CHI
It's time to show them who I really am.